Ngoài Hương quan đến vụ cuộc gái chẻ ở nghỉ An Mất Tích nhiều ngày, sau đó thì thế được kiểm thấy chết xong ở hương íên.
Chứ nay ngày 20, tăng mùi 1 năm 20 khu trăm 20 năm, các quang kể rất đổi trạc công an thành của Hàn Nội cho biết đã bắt sử dụng ý phạc được rất định là người yêu của nạn nhân.
Chứ đó, nghe nụ mùi tháng 20 năm 20, xa đình ông đầu về nở chú phường quyền mai, nghỉ An, ở đơn chính báo đến công an phường quyền mai về việc, con gái là nở tế inở, mùi chiến tuổi, mất lì lạc.
Theo ra đi, hơn 2 tháng trước, nở ra hành động làm tại một cửa hàng quân hảo, xa đó chuyển sang làm ở một công tý địa tự tệ bắt ninh.
Hí bàn nội uống nạn, cô xin gì về quyền trong sắp?
Chứ người mùi 2 tháng 20 mùi 1 cập năng nữ đến nhà gặp nữ khoảng 3 viープ, chứ hôm sau, nở xin phép ra điện cho ra hành động cho về được bản chử ra có lộ một a để đòn xe.
Ngay mùi 1 tháng 20 mùi 1, cô gọi đi báo sẽ về trong chiều, nhé không về.
Đến tối hiểm năng tháng 20 mùi 1, nơi lại nhìn sẽ về trong đêm, rồi mất lì lạc hoàn toàn.
Đến nghiệm 1 tháng 20 mùi 1, con hăng tình hương in phát hiện 1 thí tế lữ giới cho trên xong trông tình trạm bị băng dính quân trật quân người.
Chên cuộc nạn nhân có 1 thình xâm ngày 18 tháng 20 năm hành hình khu trong lịch sấu.
Dạ điện của cô gái đánh in trong sắp n液 tên chính là nờ, hí xa định nội chức đó có lý thể với bản chai ở hành động.
Công ăn tình hương in đã trời đổi thông tin với phòng cạnh rất hiện sự công an thành phố Hàn Nội.
Qua chiến phố hợp lấu tranh, phòng cạnh rất hiện sự công an thành phố Hàn Nội làm só giống hiệu của án mạc.
Và đã bắt sử nghi và phạm chính là bản trai của Nội.